aujourd'hui ce jeudi 21 septembre c'est
le début de l'Open de France de golf ici
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines à mes côtés
Philippe pilateau le directeur du Golf
National de 50 ans en Yvelines alors
cette première journée ça se passe
comment c'est humide c'était une matinée
humide mais qui vient se présager de
belles journées aujourd'hui les
conditions étaient quand même assez
compliquées mais bon on a eu quand même
un score de moins 7 avec Tom Tom Kim 18h
18e joueur mondial qui a fait ce score
incroyable aujourd'hui mais sinon voilà
tout est beau tout est propre de façon à
continuer la semaine les greens sont
comment balayer sont excellents en bombe
honnêtement ils ont bien répondu ce
matin c'est un bon test ils sont rapides
ils étaient à 11.9 ce matin au steam ce
qui veut dire que c'est une vitesse une
très bonne vitesse pour pour un tournoi
de cette qualité là et ils ont bien
répondu par rapport à toute la pluie
qu'on a eu ce matin oui tout à fait on
est sur cette 105e édition de l'Open de
France de golf qui va l'emporter cette
année ce qu'il y a des favoris qui se
dégagent bah Tom K
[Musique]
sport où c'est un c'est important de
rester dans sa bulle et dès l'instant où
il y a peut-être des éléments un peu
extérieurs c'est peut-être un peu plus
plus difficile de se mettre se mettre
dans le jeu cette peine de France c'est
le dernier avant les Jeux olympiques de
2024 ouais c'est on va dire que c'est la
dernière dernière répétition avant les
Jeux Olympiques donc pour nous c'est
très bien pour pour les équipes aussi ça
nous a permis de voir un petit peu mais
voilà dans le cadre de la préparation du
parcours parce que
préparation qui se fait maintenant poste
posté donc comme on l'a vu cet été avec
un peu de sécheresse et des conditions
qui sont quand même pas très favorables
pour pour monter le parcours à ce niveau
là donc ça nous a permis de tirer des
enseignements de façon à pouvoir
proposer un parcours incroyable en
prochain dans le cas des Jeux Olympiques
oui est-ce qu'on peut dire que déjà le
le Golf National est prêt pour
accueillir cette épreuve ouais il y a
encore du travail il y a beaucoup de
travail c'est-à-dire que là maintenant
le le focus là on finit la semaine
d'accord on finit dimanche soir on fait
un peu la fête en fait en fait ce
tournoi et ensuite à partir de la
semaine prochaine on va on va se
concentrer sur les Jeux Olympiques ce
qu'il faut c'est que c'est que le
parcours soit exceptionnel pour pour les
Jeux Olympiques et on a encore là
maintenant mais ce qui est entre entre
le mois d'octobre et puis et puis fin
juin l'année prochaine pour préparer le
parcours donc on a encore du temps mais
le temps passe vite et le focus ça va
être de proposer aux joueurs au meilleur
joueur les meilleurs joueurs mondiaux un
parcours incroyable merci à Philippe
Pilato l'Open de français jusqu'à ce
dimanche ici à 50 ans en Yvelines et on
le promet dimanche il y aura du soleil